So collective computation is how we think
biological systems solve problems.
But before delving into what collective computation
is, it's worth stepping back and thinking
about the big picture.
So in physical systems, physics is dominated
by concepts like pressure, entropy and temperature.
These arise from simple collective interactions
and provide huge insight into how the universe
works.
In biological systems, there are similar collective
concepts like metabolism, conflict management
and robustness.
But unlike in physical systems, these are
functional concepts.
Whereas in physical systems order is generated
through the minimization of energy, in biological
systems there is the additional step of information
processing.
Why biological systems have this additional
step and whether information processing makes
them fundamentally subjective and therefore
uncharacterizable by law are big open questions.
In C4, my research group here at SFI, we think
that biological systems overcome this intrinsic
subjectivity by computing — in evolutionary,
developmental or learning time — their own
macroscopic worlds, in other words, consolidating
regularities to do work more efficiently.
Examples of collective computation include
the coherent behavior that arises at the whole
organism level from the firing decisions of
the billions of neurons in your brain.
It includes the features of social structure
like the distribution of power that arise
from the status-signaling interactions in
chimpanzee and macaque groups and which have
huge implications for how conflict is managed.
It includes the collective motion of fish
schools that arises from the alignment and
velocity decisions of individual fish, and
it includes the gene regulatory interactions
in echinoderms that produce robust features
of phenotype.